と後輩の牽制です今日は肇社長にドッキリを仕掛けたいと思いますなんで本ドッキリを
仕掛けたいかというと一さんが去年の12月くらいんですねやーなぜかをレーン時計
仕掛けて来ねえかーって言ってたんですよ今回の振っ切りは肇社長にただただ嫌がらせ
してるドッキリで
ということでほとんどこれは嫌がらせですか所社長がヤラセドッキリを仕掛けてほしい
ということなのでそちらの方をぜひともやっていきたいと思いますということで
ドッキリの方なんですけど
大量の箱を用意しますその中に肇社長の大事なものを入れて土の中でイつけてもらい
まあ単純いう宝探しゲームですねその中に外れの後も用意しておきます二個開けて
何だったら腕立て100回というような感じでいくつもね箱がある中でその中で一市長
が自分の大切なものを見つけられるのかということになっております大切なものを3つ
隠したいと思います
一つ目こちらです車の限り一番大事ですそして2つ目
はいパスポートですこれめちゃめちゃ大事ですそして3つ目がこちらになります
遊戯王感です1枚ごと思うじゃないですか同じの2枚ですこちらの方がですね
amazon で頼んでいた価格で2枚で13万6000ですこちらもかけしていき
たいとおもいます
まあこれをね見つけるために必死こいてほしいということでこの3つをね味目社長勝手
に入れるまで1
俺だけのフローが待っているのかだから8月していきたいと思いますねー
ということでこちらのダンボール600用意しましたこちらは今から組み立てていき
たいと思いません
こちらの勇気をカードを大切に高校者どころつここに
しレバーんです
次はこちらの僕らはのか切れて行きたいと思います
これではじめ写真は車が使えませんはいということで3つ目こちら日本のパスポート
入れていきたいですこちらのパスポートえっと俺のじゃないかとか誰かだろうっていう
のがあると思うんですよ
本人ですこれ肇社長ですよね
しまっていうことでここから運び作りずつ外したときの備え姫たいのもあるのでそちら
の方も入れていきたいとおもいます
[音楽]
はいということで寝しなにが手伝ってもらって完成しましたーー
絶対見つかりませんそれでは再販してもらいましょう一さんを待ちます
です
犯罪まあ税金なきゃいけ絶服ってものがそうだね動きなきゃだね入っていうことで帰っ
てきた分かって殺すよはい1位近親がってるんですよ
いや絶対流したでしょ絶対やんかしたんですけどっちゃっ一家に入って言う愛って本当
に
[音楽]
ん痛いから内で部全域声物理的にはこうです
ガムテープくせえ
[音楽]
もっぷりはいい
何か起こればこのデザインは2じゃないですかああなにか俺に嫌がらせ毒消しぐねーか
なーって
はい
なので a 一さんの大事なものと思われる桃
3つをこの前に各させていただきます三
じゃあね心当たりあるんだけどさ u 4カードターン一つ目は勇気を感です
これ amazon で頼んだやつですよね amazon で頼んだやつです
セレーヌのしくでしょ違いません嘘てでよろしくを隠してない
かくしてません普通に届いてないやつ食べてさあまぞんジャージャーでその他にを二つ
あるつ農家にも太っておりますってもいいですよ
じゃあ一見つけ感じちゃうッなんですけどっなろうまあまあ
ヴァーゲてもらってもいいですしこれだってて引いてもらったほうが自分が痛い目に
遭う確率は少ないですね痛い目に遭うかク何を言ってるんだと思います
57声嫌がらせん
嫌がらせなくってからのお楽しみということでなんて本当におっしゃいますかー
痛車いっ
1回いう行政が出ている女子がいますうん
お久しぶりですはじめ社長ですというわけであれから一週間がたちました
めんどくさくでやってでめんどくせーと言いますけどこんな明二冠ないというわけで
天才の私のが思いつきました別の人間の大事なものをお腹に入れてそれここに放り込ん
だらそいつが探してくれるんじゃないか探してくれるついでに僕のものを見つけて
くれるんでへ4いうわけで気をちょっと初対面なんですけど
非常にやらの悪いユーチューバーが多分家にくるんで
何持ってこればわからないんですけどもそいつ大事なものをこの中に隠してこんなが
放り込めバー俺のむのむ探してくれるんじゃないかということでその後に探してもらい
ました
check 4
おっん
ぽって
はっはっは
ませんいらっしゃいません
そこんまあの隣で ed 分してしまえばいいじゃんの晩餐と
[音楽]
ブーブー言っね
大の字があれば安定で私は動画に大ガンダムも心増進がなくだるい痛いでエフェクは何
m 4倍系ジャクソン泣かせたいなあこの前にも海に沈んでいっ
これ
にゃる者はを
ええええええ
[音楽]
天道はられますよね塗るジェル
たくんこれでお金版である仕組みとんですね
して
ん
ます
おいお前
なんかーちょこれええ
ん
応援
[音楽]
ブーブー
本来はやー
僕だったなぁ
お前らはお前は俺がまだ触ってしまったはいお前お前の財布を
コード隠したちょ
なぜ持ってんだ質問なもの入ってるから暴力的なけれどお前は増益だそうだからもう
それはいい
軍が面白かったらゆるぞ
ただしかしなめこった子犬受けよねっ
[音楽]
voodoo
ああああああ
rip
バッハ
goo ん
入れ方かとなるでしょこれさすがに何ですかがいうかじゃ
なるともそれぞれをやってないよっけ
[音楽]
ブーブー
0日生
待ってねこれいやー左なきゃいたいなぁ
ペトリー
ぶーぶーっ
ません
恋
[音楽]
会えしなぁ
そんな僕もこのあんこある話
ニャスパー市三社町大阪ね型番あるけどよろしく
bouvet ちょっとだけでしょうー do おっあんな釣れましたぁーっは
amaran でばあちゃんはがねえ
甘いクマが退いた
[音楽]
前髪に設置 by ガーリー成長はやっぱり立だよ俺この日いけないんですよ
こ上にこうあったんですよ
頬なぁカレーセット[ __ ]がそうですけど切ってきてはけど
マジカマジカ持っていますよ
持っている
ってなめていい
もう300あれでまぁみたいなもうめんどくさいに来ちゃいました
んんやっぱりおりキッズのもう最悪や
まじ外あるカレー
はなりましょう久しぶりなんか俺と当確の音が現れるか言ってる座
暗い食らってるから罰
[音楽]
ギターよあーやばいやばい
5率だムースグってこれはクローズねーしたばっかりだから
どこだけどわからず何色になるかもわかんないですからね
ん
[音楽]
黒
ちょっとこれさん
今回商標です
ん
ます
むすっだろいきましょうそこであるぞよねどうも争うことなん
テザーそれはこちらが下ろしてもあーじゃあお互いかな
それもも月不備が花澤さんなんですっ
どうもあったよねっ終わってじゃあありがとう
ほんまにあるけどハードなメニューで戻し
ギター
amaran
いやぁー
ってなんか潰れてない2ちゃんこれで5よ見つかったんだけどまぁ俺が見つけてくれ
大事なものも絞れが見つけたもらえていいすか
それはさあ行きましょちょっと何よそれ
いいよタイガーなかったん
[音楽]
へ弔問てくださいそれを知っています
ただちょっとかっこよくなることだよそれ
ほんまのほんまにお礼眉毛前総理引いてないんですよ
外によってあったんですよ
ず混じってる方や
ぶっちゃけよゆるくなったと思ってる
祝強誰ですねそれじゃあコメダで叩いてそいつ市長や
[音楽]
うってください rename 者じゃない
会場は絶対古い家やて黒黒黒黒
パークがっちゃったりやっています待って
tue
食ったら cure
俺は解散に帰するあります俺じゃあばっか引いてねーよこのいつも見てくださいよ
[ __ ]ってもうさもさありゃー
[音楽]
ブーバーレジャー
あって車8ございまーさー
あっほっ
ああああああえっ
ウスはポスター
新しいの顔
[音楽]
plr
dee
シャワーは俺のパスポートなんだなーう
ブーン
ほんとにほんとにもう
4つ
burn down